nuevamente hablamos de economía en
directo américa de france 24 daniel
habla blandón ya está con nosotros en el
estudio para pagar la deuda pero ya sal
sin al thani porque vamos a empezar
hablando del baloncesto europeo que
comenzó anunciar sus próximos
movimientos
hola raúl pues su reunión de política
monetaria está prevista para el jueves
pero como lo adelantábamos hoy se
realizó un encuentro de emergencia para
discutir la crítica situación de los
mercados por ahora anunció que buscará
la manera de reinvertir los bonos que
compró en la pandemia una medida que de
la que no se proporcionaron por ahora
mayores detalles pero que lo que busca
es moderar la caída del mercado este
miércoles también inicia la junta de
gobernadores de la reserva federal de
eeuu que probablemente anunciará el
jueves un aumento de tasas de interés en
una cifra que el mercado estima en 0.75
puntos y de la que estaremos por
supuesto muy bien así es hablando de
mercados vamos a hablar de indicadores
como amanecieron las bolsas después de
un difícil inicio de semana las bolsas
europeas de raúl reaccionaron
fuertemente al alza a los anuncios
hechos en la reunión de emergencia del
banco central europeo entre tam las
bolsas asiáticas cerraron mixtas con la
bolsa de shanghai mirando hacia arriba a
pesar de los nuevos brotes chinos de
kobe 19 seguimos en europa a daniela
porque ese continente busca mejor dicho
en europea busca reemplazar a rusia por
israel egipto si era gorda es la
comisión europea firmó un memorando de
entendimiento con estos dos países para
permitir importaciones
significativas de gas israelí al
continente y para que firmas europeas
participen activamente en la exploración
de estos prolíficos yacimientos esto
como una manera de reemplazar las
compras de gas ruso del que dependen en
gran medida varios países del bloque
comunitario escuchemos
lo veo como un primer paso que conduce a
un acuerdo en todo el mediterráneo
porque veo que los suministros de
energía tradicionales son de la parte
más al norte y ahora se están
desplazando hacia el sur global porque
hay una gran cantidad de recursos
naturales tienes del sol tienes el
viento tienes la energía hidroeléctrica
estos son los recursos que alimentarán
la energía limpia global del futuro
danny rusia inicia su propio foro
económico internacional raúl estamos
hablando de la tradicional rueda de
inversión anual de sant petersburgo un
evento que se conoce como el análogo del
foro económico mundial de davos y que el
año pasado reunió a 13 mil 500
participantes de 140 países pero este
año espera a unos
2700 pocos detalles se conocen pero lo
que sí se sabe es que los organizadores
recomendaron a sus visitantes
extranjeros que se aseguren de llevar
dinero en efectivo no necesariamente
para hacer inversiones sino para gastar
en el país eso ya que por la cascada de
sanciones impuestas por occidente la
mayoría de franquicias de tarjeta de
crédito como visa o mastercard
funcionando en este país el programa de
más de 100 paneles que durará hasta el
sábado mostró pocos oradores por fuera
de rusia solamente algunos chinos y el
ministro de comercio de emiratos árabes
unidos- y es que rusia quiere que
confíen en su economía incluso el
gobierno dijo que hoy cree que la
recesión que provocará la guerra en
ucrania no será tan profunda como la que
se temía hace alguna semana y hoy los
nostálgicos de la tecnología van a tener
razones por qué llorar porque le decimos
adiós al internet explorer bueno que
muchos no lo quisieran como usted de
todas maneras vamos a llorar porque nos
llevamos tal frase va y es que internet
explorer de 27 años ahora se une a los
teléfonos blackberry a los módems de
acceso telefónico a muchos otros
inventos que entraron en el basurero de
la historia de la tecnología el viper si
usted se acuerda a la larga en su puesto
bueno y es que ha venido en decadencia
internet explorer sus principales
competidores que son hoy en día de
google y safari de apple concentran más
del 80 por ciento del mercado y pese a
que en su momento nueve de cada diez
usuarios usaban internet explorer ahora
son apenas un 4% un poco por encima de
otros como firefox opera o samsung a
internet desde ahora entonces raúl mg
microsoft ya no admitirá este navegador
que alguna vez fue dominante y que a los
internautas les despertaba amores y
odios por igual en su lugar estará
microsoft hecho lanzado en 2015 que dice
que tiene una navegación más rápida más
segura y más compatible danny y es que
hablamos de internet explorer y me
acuerdo con 101 llegando al internet que
se conectaba y entonces sonaba el
teléfono no podías no podías agarrar lo
que la mamá de uno que es cuelga el
teléfono pero van más allá de eso la
historia de internet explorer no estuvo
exenta de polémica no no raúl el
departamento de justicia demandó a
microsoft en 1999 porque les exigía a
los fabricantes de computadores que
usaran su navegador como condición para
obtener windows y tuvo líos con los
reguladores europeos que dijeron que
condiciones como ésta le daban ventajas
sobre sus competidores cifra el día dan
pues
224 pesos raúl este es el nuevo precio
récord del dólar informal en argentina
en este país la moneda se desvaloriza al
tiempo que la inflación repunta cada vez
más el martes se conoció que hasta mayo
los precios habían subido más del 60 por
ciento frente a igual período del año
pasado danny como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos la mañana con más y
pasamos a saludar a omar esa que nos
tiene todos los deportes